LP: I think we can be there very, very soon.
We've driven well over 100,000 miles
now totally automated.
I'm super excited about getting that out quickly.
CR: But it's not only you're talking about automated cars.
You also have this idea for bicycles.
LP: Well at Google, we got this idea
that we should just provide free bikes to everyone,
and that's been amazing, most of the trips.
You see bikes going everywhere,
and the bikes wear out.
They're getting used 24 hours a day.
CR: But you want to put them above the street, too.
LP: Well I said, how do we get people
using bikes more?
CR: We may have a video here.
LP: Yeah, let's show the video.
I just got excited about this.
(Music)
So this is actually how you might separate
bikes from cars with minimal cost.
Anyway, it looks totally crazy,
but I was actually thinking about our campus,
working with the Zippies and stuff,
and just trying to get a lot more bike usage,
and I was thinking about,
how do you cost-effectively separate
the bikes from traffic?
And I went and searched,
and this is what I found.
And we're not actually working on this,
that particular thing,
but it gets your imagination going.
CR: Let me close with this.
Give me a sense of the philosophy of your own mind.
You have this idea of [Google X].
You don't simply want
to go in some small, measurable arena of progress.
LP: Yeah, I think
many of the things we just talked about are like that,
where they're really --
I almost use the economic concept of additionality,
which means that you're doing something
that wouldn't happen unless you were actually doing it.
And I think the more you can do things like that,
the bigger impact you have,
and that's about doing things
that people might not think are possible.
And I've been amazed,
the more I learn about technology,
the more I realize I don't know,
and that's because this technological horizon,
the thing that you can see to do next,
the more you learn about technology,
the more you learn what's possible.
You learn that the balloons are possible
because there's some material that will work for them.
CR: What's interesting about you too, though, for me,
is that, we have lots of people
who are thinking about the future,
and they are going and looking and they're coming back,
but we never see the implementation.
I think of somebody you knew
and read about, Tesla.
The principle of that for you is what?
LP: Well, I think invention is not enough.
If you invent something,
Tesla invented electric power that we use,
but he struggled to get it out to people.
That had to be done by other people.
It took a long time.
And I think if we can actually combine both things,
where we have an innovation and invention focus,
plus the ability to really -- a company
that can really commercialize things
and get them to people
in a way that's positive for the world
and to give people hope.
You know, I'm amazed with the Loon Project
just how excited people were about that,
because it gave them hope
for the two thirds of the world
that doesn't have Internet right now that's any good.
CR: Which is a second thing about corporations.
You are one of those people who believe
that corporations are an agent of change
if they are run well.
LP: Yeah. I'm really dismayed
most people think companies are basically evil.
They get a bad rap.
And I think that's somewhat correct.
Companies are doing the same incremental thing
that they did 50 years ago
or 20 years ago.
That's not really what we need.
We need, especially in technology,
we need revolutionary change,
not incremental change.
CR: You once said, actually,
as I think I've got this about right,
that you might consider,
rather than giving your money,
if you were leaving it to some cause,
just simply giving it to Elon Musk,
because you had confidence
that he would change the future,
and that you would therefore —
LP: Yeah, if you want to go Mars,
he wants to go to Mars,
to back up humanity,
that's a worthy goal, but it's a company,
and it's philanthropical.
So I think we aim to do kind of similar things.
And I think, you ask, we have a lot of employees
at Google who have become pretty wealthy.
People make a lot of money in technology.
A lot of people in the room are pretty wealthy.
You're working because you want to change the world.
You want to make it better.
Why isn't the company that you work for
worthy not just of your time
but your money as well?
I mean, but we don't have a concept of that.
That's not how we think about companies,
and I think it's sad,
because companies are most of our effort.
They're where most of people's time is,
where a lot of the money is,
and so I think I'd like for us to help out
more than we are.
CR: When I close conversations with lots of people,
I always ask this question:
What state of mind,
what quality of mind is it
that has served you best?
People like Rupert Murdoch have said curiosity,
and other people in the media have said that.
Bill Gates and Warren Buffett have said focus.
What quality of mind,
as I leave this audience,
has enabled you to think about the future
and at the same time
change the present?
LP: You know, I think the most important thing --
I looked at lots of companies
and why I thought they don't succeed over time.
We've had a more rapid turnover of companies.
And I said, what did they fundamentally do wrong?
What did those companies all do wrong?
And usually it's just that they missed the future.
And so I think, for me,
I just try to focus on that and say,
what is that future really going to be
and how do we create it,
and how do we cause our organization,
to really focus on that
and drive that at a really high rate?
And so that's been curiosity,
it's been looking at things
people might not think about,
working on things that no one else is working on,
because that's where the additionality really is,
and be willing to do that,
to take that risk.
Look at Android.
I felt guilty about working on Android
when it was starting.
It was a little startup we bought.
It wasn't really what we were really working on.
And I felt guilty about spending time on that.
That was stupid.
That was the future, right?
That was a good thing to be working on.
CR: It is great to see you here.
It's great to hear from you,
and a pleasure to sit at this table with you.
Thanks, Larry.
LP: Thank you.
(Applause)
CR: Larry Page.